this is the Adric as well this gorgeous  gazelle is sadly on the verge of  extinction once spread across the Sahara  Desert it is now only found in pockets  of Chad Mali and Nigel ADRA's are  considered the largest type of gazelle  with very long legs they're built lean  and slender to survive the desert heat  their tan and brown coats blend with  their native surroundings they travel in  herds together they browse and graze  grass and leaves their strength in  numbers  is a survival tactic as they count lions  leopards and cheetahs as their predators  in the last decade their population has  decreased by over 80 percent along with  habitat destruction poaching and over  hunting for horns and meat have caused  the aedra to become critically  endangered and some estimate their  numbers at less than 300 in the wild  this is the a drug Adel  you